foreign
hey Dave help me with this real quick
um and we don't have very much time
in in a minute help me understand what
is happening with the economy because it
feels like
people are still hiring businesses are
still making money and that I don't
fully understand it but the fed's trying
to crash it yeah they're trying to run
it up against the wall and I don't
understand that well because you're a
logical human oh no one's ever said that
yeah like if it feels like they're
trying to run into a bridge and shut out
loud they want to cause unemployment
help me help me understand even the
concept the concept is is if we slow the
economy down because of unemployment
then the prices will stop going up it's
squat it's in an effort to squash
inflation the problem is that's not what
caused inflation right a speedy economy
isn't what caused inflation it was
horrible domestic policy on oil turn the
spigot off the prices go up no kidding
okay so a Biden sticker I did that for
sure yeah the other parts of inflation
were coveted related not covered related
they're corn just a lag or quarantine
related you shut down the factories on
cars
there's no cars so the price of cars
goes way up you shut down the factory on
producing Lumber there's no Lumber so
the price of lumber goes up oh wait now
we start the factory specs so now
there's cars again now there's Lumber
again it's starting to smooth out
Lumber's back down that's what I mean so
if you wait a hot minute if you wait a
hot minute and quit screwing around with
it trying to fix it with the wrong tool
quit using a hammer on a Phillips screw
I mean really and that's the problem and
that's why everybody's so pissed off
even Bernie Sanders came out and said
this is the wrong thing it's yeah well
me and Bernie Sanders agreed on
something yeah I know I felt my feet
getting cold
Dave and Bernie agree about something
well twice in six months we agreed about
I'm not near as smart economically but I
remember at the start of deer season
last year the shelves in the ammo
department and at Academy was wiped out
and then I went there the other day and
they are full top to bottom and my first
thought was the factories must be
catching up and then I thought well what
maybe I'm missing something but why are
they trying to drive this thing there's
two things that cause was precious to go
through the roof okay two potential
things that we're discussing here anyway
one type of inflation is what we had in
the 70s it was just a white hot economy
everything kept going up and everybody
got away with it and so it went up again
then it went up again then it went up
again it was just Prosperity heaped on
top of prosperity mix in a little greed
and boom okay and that's there was a
monetary policy in those days in the
late 70s early 80s very similar to this
George Volkert was have the FED back
then and um I was actually an adult and
remember this but you know and so they
did the same thing they just jacked
rates up to freeze to slow down the
economy but that econ that inflation in
the 70s was a different kind of
inflation this inflation was was
domestic oil production related and
quarantine Supply demand curve related
gotcha and if they'll if they'd leave it
alone they're going to mess it up
further that's what it feels like when I
keep opening it up first my briskets
Yeah the more I open the grill the more
I screw it up if I just leave it alone
exactly if you just let it cook man let
it cook it'll turn out